Hello and welcome,
everyone. Welcome back. This is the
second interval of the third applied
active inference symposium at the active
inference institute on August 22,
2023. This is going to be
another packed and exciting interval,
and we're kicking it off with Jean
Francois Cloutier, a Collective of
theorizers First Steps. So, JF, thank
you for joining and to you for this
presentation. And if anybody has
questions for this presentation or any
of the others, please just put it in the
live chat and I'll do it. I can. So
thanks. JF. To you.
Thank you, Daniel. I'm a software
engineer at a company called Smart Rent,
where I write software for smart home
systems. I also work on a research
project at the Active Inference
Institute called the Robotics and
Embodied Project. My current focus
is unsupervised learning in active
inference agents. In my presentation
today, which is titled A Collective of
theorizers First Steps, I'll first start
with a brief recap of the project,
then dive into recent progress,
and then I'll conclude with what I see
as the next steps of the project.
Well, since 2017, I've been
experimenting with Lego robots and
models of cognition. I do this
for my own education, because,
like I think most of us, I understand
something better when I build it. What
you see here is my latest robot model.
It's a rover. It has a whole bunch of
sensors and a number of effectors
actuators. As a matter of fact, those
sensors and actuators can be understood
as forming the marker blanket of my
robot.
Last year, I presented at the symposium
about the history of the project, its
then status, and its ambitions.
I presented a cognitive model that
implemented predictive processing from
an active inference perspective. So
there were generative models, there was
predictions, there was prediction
errors. And these
generative models animated the robots so
that they would roam, avoid obstacles,
observe their companion, and also, in a
very simplistic way, build a theory of
mind of the other robot. They could from
observations infer that the other
robot had detected food, food being
presented here as a sheet of paper on
the floor, and then would kind of try
to track the other robot to also get to
the food and fun stuff like this.
The implementation combined multi
processing and functional computing.
There was nothing probabilistic in the
implementation.
I thought maybe we'd see them in action.
That's what's presented last year. But
just to get a sense of what they do,
I have two robots here, one named Karl
and Andy. I named them before I knew I
was going to present at the conference.
So they benefited from a number
of training sessions. They learned
how to find which policies
would achieve their goals better than
others. And one here on the left.
Found the food rather right away but
got closer to the pedestal where the
beacon is that simulates the scent of
food feared was getting into
a collision and then backs off in a
hurry as we'll see the other
robot observes all this, sees the
robot backing off as being in a panic
and decides to share this
emotion and backs up as well.
So fun stuff.
From the beginning I've implemented
different cognition models but they all
have in common the fact that they
implement a society of mind.
So what is a society of mind? A society
of mind is a concept by which the
mind is not a monolithic structure
but a composition of simple actors,
independent actors that interact with
each other in simple ways. That view
of the mind was put forth by Marvin
Minsky 50 years ago. So this is not
recent.
Again, what I presented last year was a
society of mind containing a hierarchy
of, I call them cognition actors. Each
cognition actor is an independent
process, each one has a scope,
a level of abstraction as well. So for
example, you would have a cognition
actor that's concerned with the location
of food and it would have
beliefs and perceptions about food
location and these would feed into a
higher level cognition actor, let's say
food approach which is concerned about
getting closer to the food and so forth
and so on. These cognition actors
communicate again in simple ways. This
is the society of mind and they
communicate by emitting predictions,
predictions about the beliefs of other
cognition actors and they communicate by
emitting prediction errors. When
predictions made about their beliefs by
others are inaccurate that
leads to connection actors processing
these prediction errors and combining
them with their own predictions to
create an updated set of perceptions
that are synthesized into beliefs. And
these beliefs lead to actions
in order to eliminate negative beliefs
or validate positive beliefs. Now it's
from the interactions of all these kung
fu actors that seemingly purposeful
behaviors emerge. So that was successful
but learning was very limited.
This hierarchy of cognition actors
was given, was predefined and
the only learning that a robot would
do was to discover which action policies
tended to be more effective.
So clearly my robots are not monolithic
active inference agents.
So the question is why would I use
a society of mind architecture? Well,
because I subscribe to the
notion that all intelligence is
collective intelligence. This paper
makes the argument quite cogently and
I'm going to cite a number of papers
which were important to the evolution of
my thinking. This is one of them.
This paper sees intelligence as a
process, not a property. It's a process
enacted by the interacting parts
as opposed to again, a property of
individuals. So society of mind is
basically that it's actually a
number of interacting processes that
together from which emerge apparently
intelligent behaviors. Now my own
personal current definition of
intelligence is self sustaining,
inactive sense making. Sense making is
really important by autonomous agent
system in a dissipative and dynamic
environment and this guides all
the work I do in this project.
Now, if you want a description, a
detailed description of where my
project stood a year ago, there's a
paper that was published that I
published on Xenodo, which you can look
up.
Now, over the last year, I wanted to
move away from a pre built a given
society of mind and toward a learned
society of mind. I wanted to see if I
could program an autonomous robot to
evolve its society of mind through its
interactions with its environment.
Now, one might think that programming
autonomy is an oxymoron would
be a good point, but I don't think it
is. If if the program
I write and install my robot imparts
constitutive autonomy, which is enable
the robot to constitute its own
identity, and if it imparts adaptivity,
which enable the robot to modify
itself from its interactions with the
environment, then I think that the
robot will be truly autonomous.
Now, for autonomy to
exist inherently in the robot,
something in the robot must be at stake.
And in this case, it's the survival
of the robot society of mind. Now,
the physical structure of the robot is
not at stake. Its survival is
not at stake, unless, of course, it
falls off a shelf. But as I intend to
have my robot develop its society of
mind from experiences, I also expect
that if it fails, that this society of
mine will perish in its attempt to grow
and sustain itself. So that's what's at
stake going
forward in this project is the
survival of the robot society of mind.
This survival would be an expression of
being. By doing, the robot will
need to act and interact in its
environment in order to survive.
Now, whatever sense it's going to make
of its environment will then be grounded
in this survival imperative. In essence,
the robot society of mine will have skin
in the game. If this weren't the case,
then sense making would actually reside
somewhere else. It would reside in in
the mind of the programmer, in my mind
as I observe the robots. But I would
like the sense making to be grounded in
the survival of the robot's mind itself.
So that's key. Now,
what do I mean by an evolving and
growing society of mind? So instead of
the given society of mind, which I
showed earlier,
I want the cognition actors to be
created to connect with each other
dynamically through interactions with
the environment. So I want an
active, self organizing, self optimizing
collective of cognition actors. Now, is
this feasible? Well, that's a big
question. In trying to
answer this question, I'll be also
answering questions like what must be
given a priori and what can be
discovered? Well, I already have
elements of an answer. I know that the
sensors and the effectors
and the primitive
cognition actors that wrap them will be
given. This will be like what you're
born with, basically. And there might be
a metacognition actor which role
will be to oversee and guide the
evolution of all other cognition actors.
But that's my hypothesis.
I can imagine a test environment for my
robot that will test its ability to
survive. I can imagine, for example,
that as the robot
moves around or computes,
it uses a limited store of energy it's
stimulated. And that store of energy is
replenished when the robot consumes
food. And that would be by being on top
of pieces of paper, colored pieces of
paper on the floor. And I'm going to
make sure that it needs two sources of
food in order to survive. That would be
represented by a yellow paper and a
green paper, for example. So that to
prevent the robot from just simply
finding one source of food and just
stationing itself over it. So the
environment will also contain obstacles.
So the robot will need to learn how to
navigate, avoid obstacles, locate
different sources of food, get to them,
and make sure that it alternate between
various sources of food in order to
survive. And the society of mind that
will evolve, will hopefully evolve
to successfully do this. Else if it
doesn't, then it will shrink as
resources disappear and essentially
die. So that's what it's at stake for
this robot.
Now, this effort employs a number of
frameworks, and by framework,
I mean a useful system of concept and
constraints that guide the
implementation. Well, there's obviously
the free energy principle and the Active
inference framework.
However, I see this, the Acactive
Inference, as an as if framework.
It describes the what what must be
achieved in this case, reduction of
the agents, variational, free energy.
But it doesn't guide me as to the
implementation, how to build the robot.
For this, I need as is frameworks.
And I'll be using two
frameworks, one which I've been using
since the beginning of the project,
which is the Actor model.
The Actor model views computation as
a diversity of processes, processes that
are independent, have their own private
internal state, and who communicate with
one another strictly through messages.
Yesterday in Enterprise One, Keith
Duggar presented on the Actor model and
made the case that we should use the
actor model to implement active
inference agents. Well, I wholeheartedly
agree with them. The other framework
that I'm going to be using is a special
case of symbolic AI called the App
Perception Engine. And much of the
presentation will be about the App
Perception Engine and its
implementation.
So here's where we are is the project is
located at the intersection of Active
Inference as a domain, the Wet and
Society of Mind as an architecture,
and symbolic AI as a form of computing.
So that's where the project is, at this
intersection.
So where to begin? So I want to dive
into a more extensive form
of learning. And the first step,
logically, is to learn how to predict.
So I want to enable
a single cognition actor.
We'll start with a single cognition
actor to learn how to make sense of its
local environment, its so called unvelt.
And making sense implies,
at a minimum, to be able to predict
incoming sensations. So it needs to
learn to predict.
So what will be given to a cognition
actor? Well, there will be a history of
sensations broken into discrete
units of time. So time n minus
three and N minus two, n minus one time
n, which is the present moment.
So these would be remembered
observations. And then what we want to
get out of this is the ability to
predict the next incoming set
of sensations at time t equals n plus
one, n plus two. And for this,
to be able to predict future
observations, we need some kind of
predictor function that is learned from
the remembered observation. Now,
this predictive capability can be built
in two very general ways. One is from
statistics, so doing pattern analysis
and being able to predict what's most
probable, which is the standard current
machine learning approach. Or we could
predict from an understanding of the
observations by developing a causal
model of
what produced these sensations,
and from this understanding,
predict what rationally should be
observed next.
So this is all about sense making.
And now what is sense making? How do I
understand sense making? Well,
to rationally predict incoming sensory
inputs, one must make sense of them.
That's what making sense means to me.
And to make sense of sensory inputs
means to derive meaningful experiences
from them. It's not just data, it's not
just pieces of data. There must be
meaningful experiences. And by
experience, I mean a conceptualization
of the sensations and a unification of
them in time and space. So making sense
of these inputs will mean to produce
meaningful experiences that are
conceptualizations and unifications of
the sensations. Now, an experience is
meaningful if it is
underwritten by a causal model. So the
experience is
perceived as the consequences of a
latent generative model, generative
process that we have modeled.
And I want meaning to be inherent to the
agent. And that only happens if the
agent is truly autonomous and if this
meaning is grounded in the survival
imperative, as discussed earlier.
So how does experiencing work? How can
that be put into computer code?
Surprisingly for this, we refer to the
philosophy of Emmanuel Kant. Emmanuel
Kant took a reverse engineering
approach, asking himself what must
entities do to achieve experience?
This is akin to the free energy
principles high Road, which can be
paraphrased as what must organisms do to
maintain their existence? So Emmanuel
Kong tried to reverse engineer
cognition,
asking himself what's the minimal
cognitive apparatus needed by an entity
to have experiences? And that
he documented in his critique of pure
reason. Just a little parenthesis.
The meaning of the title Critique of
Pure Reason is not what I thought it
was. It actually translates more closely
to the case for April. Cognition
critique is a legal term is where you
make your case and pure reason we
translate nowadays. April cognition.
So his work
wanted to establish what must happen to
create an experience that's coherent,
that is unified in time and space,
and to reverse engineer cognition as a
system that is both complete and
essential, that is minimal.
Okay, so I'm going to try to
give you the postage stamp version
of Emmanuel Kant's theory
focusing on the Synthetic Unity of
Apperception. Well, first of all,
there's the real world, which is outside
of our direct experience. It's the
pneumonia. It's forever hidden from us
as an as is reality,
but it impinges on our sensorium.
And then so we have a number of
intuitions, sight, sound, touch, smell
that are initially separate,
and then we need to network
them, connect them both in time and in
space. In space is
sound. And the sight describing
a single thing is
one thing behind or inside another.
And in time, is this happening before,
after something else?
And then at a higher level, meaning is
given to these networked, intuitions,
sensations via concepts and
judgments, rules which are
generalizations as to what can and
cannot be.
And this is what we experience.
Now, it turns out that synthetic
Unity of Apperception is a
blueprint for automating sense making.
It's kind of interesting, I think, that
18th century philosophy would be
relevant to 21st century technology
development. And this is what happened
and was published by Richard Evans and
all in the paper Making Sense of Sensory
Input, where they developed the App
Perception Engine. They took synthetic
Unity of Apperception as software
requirements and successfully
implemented them into a piece of
software, the App Perception Engine,
and applied it to a number of exercises
where they got a very good result. So
the App Session Engine is in an instance
of machine learning. It's unsupervised
machine learning, and it operates on
very small data sets and
generates human readable generative
models. When I read the paper, I
realized, well, that's exactly what my
robot needed.
So what does an app perception engine
do? Well, given a sequence of observed
states, it finds
a generative model that can recreate
past states but most importantly,
predict future states. And the state is
defined as a set of simultaneous
observations, sensations, intuitions.
So an apperception engine searches
for a causal theory that can recreate
observations. I say searches because
this causal theory is not determined by
the observations. It has to be found.
It has to be discovered. But once
it is found, then it can be validated
against the observations and see if it
can recreate them and augment them into
the future as well as into the past.
So what is a causal theory?
A causal theory is a logic program that
has a number of components.
In the causal theory, there will be the
objects and the predicates from the
observed relations. So from the
observations, we can extract what
objects were observed and what
properties of these objects were
observed and maybe what relationships
these objects were observed. That's the
start. Then we have latent object types,
objects and predicates. So we may want
to imagine causal theory, imagines
hidden objects, maybe hidden types of
objects and maybe hidden properties and
relationships between objects,
latent meaning unobserved. And given
both the observed and unobserved objects
and predicates, it derives
rules, first of all constraints on those
predicates, what's permissible. So for
example, being in front of A
cannot be in front of B and at the same
time behind B. So an object cannot be in
front of another and behind it. So there
are constraints on predicates and then
there are rules that apply to any
simultaneous sets of observations, what
they must conform to. Then there are
rules that given a state, will infer the
next state and then maybe some initial
state from which we can run
the causal theory.
So what makes a causal theory unified?
Well, first of all it needs to be
unified in order to make sense of the
observation. There are various
dimensions. So if a causal theory
involves a number of objects, all these
objects must be directly or indirectly
related. There's no object that just
floats in space totally independent of
the other objects, so they must all be
related. So they're spatially unified.
All predicates that make up the causal
theory, like on,
off, behind, in front, they must be
constrained so that, for example, in
front cannot be at the same time as
behind or that a light cannot be both
turned on and turned off. So there's
some restrictions on the predicates
and that creates conceptual unity. And
then there's static unity where all
simultaneous relations must satisfy the
static rules, and temporal unity, where
all the states must be sequenced by
causal rules. We'll see examples.
So let's start
with an example here of a set
of observations. What we are observing
are two lights and the lights can
either be at any discrete moment in
time, either on or off. So here we have
a sequence of observations and
one moment in time. The first light was
off and the second light was on. Then
the first light was on, the second light
was off,
then both were on, et cetera. And I
put the gray bars there to show that
maybe the observations are incomplete.
So at one stage we can only see the
second light or there may be other
lights or other objects that we do not
see, but that's what we observe.
So you feed these observations
in discrete time into the apperception
engine and the perception engine
searches for a causal theory that
when applied to an initial condition,
let's say that light A is off and light
B is on. It will create a trace
of recreated observations. That cover
is a superset, matches the initial
observations. And if this happens, then
our causal theory is a good one. Now,
the causal theory may infer the
existence of hidden objects, hidden
relations, and whatnot it may actually
need to.
So here's an example of a causal theory
that is generated by my own
implementation of the App perception
engine. Because I re implemented the App
perception engine as described in the
paper by Richard Evans and all,
and I ran it
on the set of observations about lights
on two lights, one on, one off at any
point in time. And it came up with
it found a result. It found the result
in 64 seconds. It was a perfect match.
And it actually invented
a relationship, which it called thread
One, which we can let's
imagine that it actually means connects
to. And it found a static
rule and a causal rule. It said that a
light is on at any moment in time.
A light is on if a light that connects
to it is off. And it found a causal rule
that said a light turns
off if it connects
to another light that was also off.
So that's how the lights change over
time, the status of on and off. And it
came up with initial conditions that
said that, well, A connects to,
first of all, that there's an object
one, a light called object one that we
don't see, but is there, we imagine is
there, that A connects to it. The light
object one connects to B, and the light
B connects to object one. So that's the
causal rule that it discovered.
Now, if we run this causal rule, we
produce a trace. And as you
can see, the trace matches the
observation. It adds a new object.
So the coverage being excellent, being
perfect in this case, and our causal
theory is a good one. It's actually a
perfect one. It's not necessarily the
only one, though.
So is this causal theory unified?
So going back to Dr. Kant's requirement
of synthetic unity, of Apperception,
not every causal theory will do, though
it may predict correctly, it may
not be meaningful unless it is unified.
Well, we saw the four
dimensions of unification. Is it
spatially unified? Well, all our objects
are connected directly or indirectly
to each other. That's good.
So we have spatial unification. Do we
have conceptual unification? So we have
this new predicate. We have two
predicates, right? Pred One, which we
translate to, connects to, and then the
predicate that says whether the light is
on or off. Well, we have a constraint
that says that a light can
only be connected to one other light.
So pred one has a constraint on it
that says it's
exclusive. So an object cannot pred
one to two objects cannot connect to two
objects. That's a constraint that was
discovered and part of the causal
theory. And also implicitly,
the on relation of the predicate
has the value on or off, and it cannot
be both at the same time. So it's
conceptually unified. Is it statically
unified? Are the static
rules obeyed. Well, for example, the
static rule would say that given that B
connects to A, if B is off,
then A must be on. So if you look at any
place where B is off, a is going to be
on. And you could do that for every
other light and relationships between
lights. So they all obey the static
rule. And the causal rule says,
for example, here, that if B connects to
A, then if A was off, then B must turn
off. So if you look at B, let's say
B was off.
Yeah, I'm sorry, if B connects to
A,
and yes, and if A
was off, B must be off.
So if A was off, B becomes off
the next step. So that's correct as
well. So statistically we are
true, and temporarily we are true.
We are unified. And of course, that we
get a thumbs up from Dr. Kant,
our causal theory is unified. Thus it
makes sense of the observations of the
sensory inputs. Now,
it's no accident that Kant
would be would figure in an active
inference project. There is a link
between active inference and Kant, and
it runs through the celebrated 19th
century German engineer Herman
von Hemholz. He was a disciple of Kant
and he developed the theory of visual
perception that operationalized Kant's
epistemology. And in fact, it
anticipates predictive processing. In
1995, Peter Day and Jeff
Hinton developed the Helmholtz machine.
Name is in his hunter. It is a
type of artificial neural network that's
trained to create a generative model
from an original set of data. And it can
account for the hidden structure of the
data. So as you
see, there's a link which is discussed
and elaborated in this paper, which is
very interesting paper. All right,
so close parentheses.
So we've looked at the App Perception
engine from the perspective of
philosophy. So now let's look
at it through the lens of machine
learning.
The observations constitute a training
set. It's a very small one. And the
Appetition engine is the
learning algorithm. And what is learned,
the output is a causal theory.
So the learning process is unsupervised
logical inferencing, and the
output is a human readable logic
program. So we see here that there's
some profound differences with the
more popular form of machine learning in
that the training set is really small,
that the product of the
learning is actually a human readable
artifact, in this case, a logic program.
So this is the training set.
As inputted lights
led, a turned off at
time one, b turned on at time one,
a turned on at time two, b turned off at
time two, et cetera, et cetera. So
that's the training set and
you feed this into the perception
engine's algorithm and out comes a
causal theory. So in a
little bit more details what the
algorithm is and does. First, it
extracts the observed object
extent objects, the object types and
predicates from the observations. So we
have on, we have object A, object B.
We have led as an object type. So that's
all part of the observations and that
becomes part of the extent vocabulary.
Then the application engine imagines
unobserved objects, types and predicates
for the relationships and properties,
and that becomes a latent vocabulary.
So there's a step of imagination. Then,
using the combined vocabulary, both the
extent and latent vocabulary combined,
it looks for a unified causal theory, a
set of constraints, rules and initial
conditions that obey the
constraints of synthetic unity
of apperception. Once it has this
causal theory and with initial
conditions, it applies the causal theory
to these conditions and produces a
trace. It recreates observations
if you want and augments them and
extends them into the future. Now it
looks at this trace and compares it with
the initial observations for coverage
and decides if this is a good causal
theory or not. Then it also looks at the
causal theory complexity, how many
rules, how complex are the rules, et
cetera, and measures for complexity. So
if we have a choice between two causal
theories of equivalent coverage,
the App Perception Engine will select
the least complex one using Occam's
Razor. Now, if you look at this
algorithm, you'll see that the boxes in
green are not deterministic.
This is where search happens. We can
posit different kinds of objects. We can
find different kinds of rules. So this
is where search happens.
Now, app perception is implemented using
logic inference. Actually, it uses three
forms of logic inference. There's the
one that we're more familiar with,
which is deduction, where given rules
and causes, we infer the effects. Then
there's induction. Where given causes
and effect, we look for the rules. This
is what science does, right? Looking for
rules that would account for effects
given the causes. Then there's
abduction, where given the rules and
given what we observe the effects,
we're looking for the causes. In this
case, we're looking for the latent
objects, the latent relationships
between these objects. And then you can
combine both abduction and induction,
where you're given effects, essentially
observations, and you're looking for
both causes and rules, which is what the
App Perception Engine does. And this is
where in the algorithm, these kinds of
inferences are at play. So positing
latent objects, that's a form of
abduction, imagining causes,
finding the rules, well, that's clearly
a form of induction. And then applying
the rules of a
causal theory to some initial conditions
to create a trace, well, that's
deduction. We have the causes, the
initial conditions, we have the rules,
causal theory, and then we produce a
trace, the effects. So that's deduction.
So the App Perception Engine uses all
forms of logical inference.
Now, just a reminder that the output of
the App Perception Engine, that is what
is learned is actually human readable.
You may want to compare that to a
large array of floating points produced
by traditional, the more popular form.
Of machine learning nowadays. So here,
this is what's actually produced by the
app reception engine. As it runs on a
set of observations, it produces a
logic program that is human readable.
When you look at it, the only thing you
need to kind of guess is what is
meant by pred one. And if you think,
well, maybe it means connects to maybe
the lights are connected underneath a
board out of sight of
the observer.
But finding a unified causal theory is
hard. So we have to guess what the
latent objects and predicates are. What
are the hidden lights, what are the
hidden relationships between lights?
And we have to discover what constraints
might apply on the predicates and what
are the initial conditions from which we
want to recreate a trace. What are the
static rules that apply to simultaneous
observations? And then what are the
causal rules that given observations at
time T will predict observations at time
T plus one? This is hard.
As a matter of fact, it's non
polynomially hard. The search space
grows exponentially with the size of the
input, which is the size of the extent
and latent vocabulary. So just
like in chess, you can't predict to the
end the consequence of a move because of
common turbo explosion. With the app
perception engine, you cannot
systematically traverse the entire space
of possible causal theories to find a
good one because it's impossibly large.
So the job of the apperception engine is
to find a causal theory in a
ridiculously large haystack.
How to do this? In my implementation,
I follow the
recommendations and I follow also the
implementation in Richard Evans'paper
by breaking the search space into
chunks. First there's a region
and the region says so how many latent
object types, objects and predicates
will we allow? So what is the limit of
imagination of the cognition
actors that is trying to apperceive a
causal theory? What are the limits of
its imagination? And within that region
of bounded imagination,
we carve it into templates
where we say, okay, we're going to use
these latent objects types, these latent
objects. And so basically, what
vocabulary, specific vocabulary we're
going to be using? We're going to use
object one. We're going to use object
pred one on top of the observed
on predicate and observed A
and B lights. And we're going to set the
maximum complexity on the rules and see
if we can find causal theories that fit
this template. So this is a carving up
of the search space and having broken
the search space into regions and
templates, we have scopes
in which to apply Heuristics. Now. Why
heuristics? Because the systematic
traversal cannot be done in reasonable
time. There's just too many candidate
causal theories to look at to find a
good one. So we use Heuristics.
We find ways of maybe getting to a good
solution faster at the risk of missing
it. But at least we'll have an
answer or no answer in a reasonable
amount of time. And there's a number of
heuristics that I've implemented in my
implementation of the app assetron
engine. Well, there's time boxing. At
some point, you'd spend no more than
this amount of time looking into a
region or into a template. There's
multitasking. Well, the problem is
actually, as they say, embarrassingly
parallel. You can explore multiple
regions and multiple templates in
parallel and so make good use of a
multicore computer. You want to
make sure you don't repeat yourself. So
you don't want to traverse the same
region twice or look at the same causal
theory twice. You want to satisfy
maybe a good enough theory is just fine.
We don't want to look for the perfect
one necessarily. We may not have time.
You want to fail early. If you're in a
region where nothing good is found, you
may want to leave it quite quickly at
the risk of maybe not finding a good one
that is just over the horizon. But you
want to be impatient. You want to throw
the dice. You may want to kind
of mix it up so that every time you run
the app Perception Engine on the same
problem, you may find a
different solution first. You want
to go for the simpler solution first.
You may not want to try everything,
just sample some. You want to start with
the easiest part of the search base
first, be judicious and so forth and so
on. And most importantly, be selective.
So reject any causal theory that would
fail the constraints of unity of
apperception. With all these in place,
my implementation of the app Perception
Engine gives pretty good results. So
here I did a run. This is not cherry
picked. I decided to do one series of
seven runs and collect
the data and show it. And in this
run, I set up the apparition engine to
only accept a perfect causal theory,
one that would produce a trace that
totally covers the observation. And I
did seven runs. The first one succeeded,
found it in 4 seconds. The second one,
it took 102 seconds. So there's some
randomization in the order in which
things have searched if luck is
involved. As I said, the third one,
1 second, that was pretty cool.
The fourth one, well, took 204 seconds,
then 90, 612, 99. So quite
a good distribution here. Now, I said,
okay, I'm going to run the app
Perception Engine again on the same
training set that I showed earlier,
those two lights. But this time I said,
I'm going to accept the theory that has
85% or more coverage. So it
recreates the observations well enough,
but not perfectly. And I time boxed
it to 30 seconds. So you have 30 seconds
to find it. Go. The first run,
it find a causal theory with 75%
accuracy immediately.
Then the same accuracy, same coverage.
10 seconds. 11 seconds. It hit 29
seconds. It found a perfect one.
Then eleven, it found 87% coverage and
stopped right there. That's good enough.
75 again, 100% is the first one it found
above 85 in 18 seconds and 75% 0 second.
So a good distribution again, so we're
getting into reasonable times. We're not
talking about hours here, we're talking
about seconds. And I'm hoping to do
further optimizations and bring it down
to something even smaller so that a
cognition actor can say, I want to
make sense of these observations,
query the apperception engine, and get
an answer, a causal theory within maybe
a couple of seconds. That's my hope.
Now, something interesting here. It so
happens that what makes it hard for the
app perception engine to find a good
causal theory is formally equivalent to
what makes cognitive science as a whole
hard. And this paper here makes the case
and proves the case quite cogently.
So cognizant
science wants to find models, functions
or algorithms that explain,
account for situated behaviors.
So you feed into
the cognitive science machine pairs of
situations and behaviors, and you want
to come out of it a model, an
explanation, a function, or an algorithm
that accounts for it.
Well, the paper makes the case
that if the explanation is
to be bounded in size, then the
problem is computable, but it's not
tractable in the sense meaning that it's
combinatorially explosive. But once you
have a solution, it is computable and
tractable to verify that the solution is
good, that it accounts for the
data that you're trying to understand.
Well, this is equivalent, formally
equivalent to what the app perception
engine is doing.
My implementation was done in prologue.
I will not go into the details. It's
about 1000 lines of prologue. I'll just
say that prologue is a programming
language that use deductive inference
as its model of computation with
backtracking. So essentially it
searches for a solution and will
backtrack if it took the wrong branch
if you want. And we'll look for
a different way of satisfying a line of
the program. So let's just say
that it makes traversing a search space.
We get traversing a search brains for
free when we program in prologue. I
won't go into any more details, but you
can see some prologue code here. And the
fun thing is that a prologue
program is akin to a logical description
of the problem it's trying to solve. I
think it's very cool. And prologue
environment was augmented by something
called constraint handling rules, which
is an extension to prologue that adds
abductive reasoning. So basically in the
program, you can say, assume this is
true until proven otherwise, and the
CHR rules are there to verify
if it can be proven otherwise. So,
again, I'm not asking you to understand
this code at all, but I want you to
realize that this code is the code that
actually executes a causal theory,
both the static and causal rules to
build traces. It is that small. It's
very powerful. So combining prologue and
CHR, I found extraordinarily powerful.
I'm very excited about it. I'm a
programmer. Next steps.
Well, next steps, now that we've solved
individual learning by cognitive actors,
well, I want to move to beliefs from
sensations and to policies to validate
or eliminate beliefs.
A lot of these beliefs actually fall out
of our perception. Latent objects and
latent relationships and properties can
be considered as beliefs. Then there are
other kinds of beliefs that can be
obtained from what's been perceived.
There will be introspective beliefs that
communicate how the cognition
actor is doing in terms of competence,
predictionary rates, how well its
apperception is doing, and whether
it is engaging with other cognition
actors. Is it relevant? I will have
feelings which will provide normativity
to these beliefs. So if feelings are
signals of risk to homeostasis,
loss of resources, physical damage,
too many prediction errors so that's
anger, pain, and fear and feelings will
taint beliefs over time and tainted
beliefs, good beliefs,
bad beliefs will want to be eliminated
or validated through policies that
will be synthesized by the cognition
actor. And each cognition actor will
make available to others its API.
What predictions can be made about the
beliefs of this cognition actor? What
actions are available to others to
be asked of the cognition
actor? And then as cognition actors
connect to one another, as the
conjunction actors form the umbelt of
other cognition actors, then a
conjunction actor will be able to
predict the beliefs of others, will be
able to compose policies
made out of actions that are implemented
by other cognition actors. And
eventually, we'll have a society of
mind, which is a bunch of intersecting
boom belts. So that's
it. So I see the
society of mine is a complex system of
collective theorizers. And I'm going to
try going further with this project to
answer the question if collective
theorizers can self organize to actively
sustain itself. So thank you to
the Active Inference Institute for
inviting me to present and for providing
a home for this project and for the
constant support and encouragement.
I'll see you later on Discord. Thank
you. Awesome. Thank you,
JF. Just to conclude the session, I'll
read two questions and let's
maybe address them in an upcoming
Robotics and embodied meeting. So if
you're excited about this project,
certainly we all are and about symbolic
active inference, join the Discord and
participate in the Robotics and
Embodied. But I'll drop these two
questions from David Williams in the
Chat, who wrote, one, how important is
conducting this work in real world
versus simulation? And two, what tools
or components are missing in the
robotics toolkit to make this research
easier and better? I know those are
things that you have a lot of thoughts
on, so I'll look forward to discussing
with you more. Thank you, JF.
Thank you. Peace.
All right.
See you.